Mr Ben first question I guess do you
think he was right to say that you've
eliminated thousands of terrorists uh
Hamas is claiming and we have to take
their figures at their word and I'm not
sure how credible they are but they're
claiming 7,000 Palestinians have died
since October the 7th but we don't know
how many of those are terrorists and how
many are completely innocent civilians
do
we well Israel and the idea of always uh
Target uh the Hamas terrorists uh yes
sometimes the Hamas terrorists use
civilians as human Shields but I
wouldn't trust hamas's uh statement as
we saw just a few days ago uh it was
Islamic Jihad who shot a rocket at a
gazin hospital Hamas claimed it was
Israel the whole world uh echoed that
for about 24 hours until it turned out
that it's a total lie and it indeed was
Islamic Jihad so I I wouldn't assign to
too much weight to their words
especially given that they're a group of
uh rapists and murderers so why would
you trust them no no I I completely
concur that you don't have to take their
figures uh just because they say these
are the figures but what is clear is a
lot of civilians innocent people uh as
well as I presume some terrorists have
being killed so far by the Israeli uh
response with the air strikes it's clear
also that a major ground Invasion will
massively increase the number of
innocent people who die and I've asked
this question to a lot of guests in the
last 3 weeks I'll ask it to you what is
a proportionate response because people
are already saying look 1500 people in
Israel were killed it was barbaric it
was evil it was an act of horrible
terrorism but if 7,000 people or several
thousand whatever the correct number is
already been killed in Palestine what is
the number which becomes unpalatable
even for people on the Israeli
side
so it's not about uh proportionality to
what happened it's about preventing what
will happen what we've realized is that
we have a Isis State on our border uh
people who will rape murder dismember
bodies kill babies from point blank so
it's not about what happened it's about
the future how do we uh protect and
defend Israel there's only one way total
eradication of Hamas so when you think
about proportionality it's not about the
the numbers it's about how we get them
out but I will say uh Piers that IDF is
very focused on uh preventing
unnecessary deaths that's why we went
out of our way according to
international law and we allowed roughly
800,000 gazans from northern Gaza to
evacuate away from Harm's Way so in the
the theater of operations as has been
already made Republic is going to be
primarily Northern Gaza and we're
allowing ample time giving precaution
warning you know bending over backwards
to reduce the amount of uh civilian
casualties but what happens to those
800,000 gazans if all their homes are
completely destroyed what do they come
back to do they come back if they can't
come back where do they go where do they
live look uh Israel's responsibility is
not to provide housing and a high
quality of lives to an enemy State I
don't recall America or Britain uh
asking those questions about Japan or
Germany during World War II uh our goal
is to minimize civilian casualties but
our main goal is to eradicate Isis Hamas
that's the main goal now we W in the
southern part which is sort of the Safe
Haven area or we've created Safe Haven
corridors we are allowing anyone to
provide water food and Medicine in the
safe haven corridors so we're about
protecting lives the fact that uh
thousands of uh gazen and Hamas citizens
and uh uh terrorists went in and raped
and killed Israelis yes it has
meaningful consequences that they
brought about themselves I also want to
point out uh that contrary to what
people think there were also many gazin
civilians that entered uh Israel and
just horrible things for example we we
have uh evidence in in videos of uh
gazin civilians coming out and saying
that girl we don't want to murder keep
her for rape I want to rape her that one
we murder that one we take hostage so
it's you know the the notion that Hamas
is totally divorced from um the massive
public support of gazin is untrue having
said that we still are going out of our
way to allow uh the citizens away from
Harm's
Way Queen Ria of Jordan uh was very
vocal this week gave a very impassioned
interview in which she accused Israel of
being an aparti regime uh said that
there's always a distinction in the west
between Israel's right to self-defense
against any right of Palestinians to
self-defense which is always categorized
as terrorism she said that whilst what
happened October the 7th was savagely
barbaric why is that terminology never
used about what Israel does to
Palestinians what was your reaction to
Queen Ria and that
interview well she totally lied and said
simply wrong and reprehensible things
let's let's undo the unpack this she
talks about a part hide let's talk about
a part hiide there's about a million and
a half Israeli Arabs they vote in the
elections they have one ballot like I do
there's uh uh over a dozen Arab members
of knesset uh we have Arab Supreme Court
judges so we have Arabs even serving uh
some of them in the military they enjoy
full equal rights in Israel so saying
that Israel is an apart heide State
simply has nothing to do with the facts
if she wants to bring some facts to
substantiate her her lies I challenge
her bring me facts that show that Israel
is a paride a b regarding the uh
barbarism and Savage
of uh of Hamas Israel never in our 75
year history did anything near what they
did I I want to explain I I today spoke
to a family the Zach family the parents
and the younger brother were were
murdered they were waiting in the
shelter and the the the sister uh uh
Hadar was not there she told me that the
the dad was holding the shelter handle
so the terrorists can't come in what the
terrorists did they burnt the whole
house and suffocated the mom the dad and
Young Brother Sagi his only comfort was
they found Sagi and his mom hugged on
the bed in the shelter as they were
suffocating this is something that no no
decent person would ever do so shame on
Queen Rea shame on her uh and and the
fact that she can say these blatant lies
is simply
deplorable
many people uh in Israel 80% I think in
the latest poll believe that Benjamin
Netanyahu should express some personal
responsibility and apology for the
catastrophic failure of security and
defense on October the 7th you have now
said publicly that you feel responsible
for what happened on your watch as prime
minister which may have contributed to
the failings why has Benjamin Netanyahu
not done the same and should he
[Applause]
you'd need to ask him uh I don't want to
stand here and criticize the Israel's
prime minister I may have uh profound uh
differences and and uh thoughts but I
have a habit where I don't criticize uh
Israeli leaders during war and certainly
not in international
press but there's no doubt it was a
catastrophic failure and he is the guy
at the Top If you had been prime
minister which you were several years
ago and this had happened on your watch
would you have
resigned I don't want to go into into
that because again it's a domestic
Israeli politics uh I have my set of uh
ethics and standards that I adhere to
for all my life you have to uh send all
these questions to prime minister
netanel we've got a war to
win both uh President Biden and indeed
Queen Ria and many others are saying
that the only way this gets resolved is
politically with people getting around a
table I think it's pretty clear that
cannot be done as long as Hamas are in
charge of Gaza and certainly uh depends
if there's any Hamas left at this the
end of this ground Invasion anyway um
you said in June 2013 the following uh
you said I have a friend who's got
shrapnel in his rear end and he's been
told it could be removed surgically but
it would leave him disabled so he
decided to live with it there are
situations where insisting on perfection
can lead to more trouble than it's worth
and your quote which became known as
shrapnel in the butt quickly became
widely known as your view of the
Palestinian problem and you've always
been resolutely opposed to a two-state
solution do you think that kind of
rhetoric helps and do not think now that
the only way out of this actually is to
have a two-state
solution I uh totally disagree I think
uh what people don't realize and I think
that you gave me a good opportunity now
appears to emphasize we provided the
Palestinians with a fullblown
Palestinian state in Gaza in 2005 since
I think most your viewers do not know
this Israel pulled out of Gaza pulled
out all its soldiers pulled out all the
Israelis living there 8,000 Israelis
handed the keys to the Palestinian
Authority there was no Siege no blockade
nothing and they had the opportunity to
turn their state into Singapore and from
the very first moment Piers they began
shooting Rockets firing rockets at our
towns since then we've had tens of
thousands of rockets from the very Gaza
that we
evacuated so they had the full
opportunity and they blew it we did the
same thing in Judean Samaria aka the
West Bank in during Osa Accords we
handed we pulled out out of of all the
major cities ramala nablas Kon janin
gave the keys to the uh PA and what we
got from year 2000 and on was a barrage
of suicide attacks in Tel Aviv and in
hia and Jerusalem so what I've learned
I'm a very simple guy I look at the
facts and by the way all Israelis the
overwhelming majority of Israelis agree
every time we hand land over to them
give them the responsibility in the keys
they turn it into a terror base against
us so how stupid can we be to try this
failed approach for the fourth and fifth
time we need a different approach and I
don't want to govern the Palestinians I
have no desire most Israelis do do not
desire to govern them so make no mistake
but certainly we cannot allow them to
have any Arms any army any Terror
organization and the first and foremost
thing that prevents peace
is having Kamas so there's no way to
even imagine uh peace as long as Kamas
exists on uh this
territory